welcome everyone uh i'm really excited
to welcome dr andrew harris uh here
today uh not least because his work on
inquiry and archaeology resonates with
the important work of our recently
departed dear colleague the
archaeologist michael coe who as many of
you know has had a long history of
important work into inkorian archaeology
and also as many of you know here at
yale we have a long-standing scholarly
engagement with cambodia
under the stewardship of my wonderful
colleague ben kiernan in the history
department
i'm also excited for the ways that
andrew's work might intersect with a
burgeoning interest in buddhist studies
here at yale which is guided by another
of my wonderful colleagues juan su kim
who is also the chair of the council of
east asian studies
dr harris uh recently competed completed
his phd in archaeology at the university
of toronto where he is currently still
based while directing the encore vihara
project which is a collaboration between
cambodia's apsara national authority and
the archaeology center of the university
of toronto which is dedicated to the
research excavation and publication of
early theravada buddhist archaeology at
encore
dr harris is a previous recipient of the
robert h n ho dissertation fellowship
and buddhist studies and has published
his work in world archaeology and
medieval worlds with upcoming
publications in artephus aca asian
archaeology and the brill handbook in
memory studies which we just heard about
briefly from my colleague guantran
i have much more to say about andrew's
work and how excited i am to have him
here but nobody came here to listen to
me so i'm gonna pause here and just ask
you all to join me as we welcome dr
andrew harris to our virtual series his
talk is entitled the introduction of
theravada buddhism to encore cambodia
circa 13th through 16th centuries
mapping and interpreting religious
change through the archaeological record
so please join me in welcoming dr harris
so i want to thank of course the center
for southeast asian studies for inviting
me to their brown bag seminar series
it's a great honor to be able to present
all in front of you um as
eric mentioned my name is andrew harris
i've never been called doctor so many
times in a row at this point so i'm very
happy about that
i am a research associate at the
archaeology center at the university of
toronto and i'm also a sessional
lecturer at trent university durham
so before i get started i want to
acknowledge several people organizations
and funding bodies who have been
integral to
uh getting my research completed and
completing my dissertation
especially those members of appstar
national authority
who have been generous with granting us
permits and rights to excavate the
incredible archaeological record of
cambodia and encore
so today's talk
uh is primarily going to cover as the
title suggests the religious transition
and transformation of encore and notably
encore tom in cambodia
and we're going to cover a few distinct
topics first starting with religion
statecraft and temple cosmology and what
is often anachronistically known as
indianized cambodia in southeast asia
i'm going to cover a little bit about
angkor thom the theater of early
tarabata buddhist place making at encore
what entails buddhist terrorist
archaeology and theravada monastic
construction at encore
then we'll talk about converted temples
which are the major evidence for
evolving perceptions of past religious
spaces
then i will talk about social memory a
heuristic known as foci of memory which
i'll discuss what that is later and how
that affected buddhist terrorist
construction as well as the 16th century
restoration of angkor wat which is
probably the best known event
within encore's theravada buddhist
archaeological record and then finally
i'll discuss briefly how
mapping religious transition the
archaeological record might take place
but the major thesis woven through this
presentation is that theravada buddhism
could not have been successful in its
spread at encore without a standardized
reckoning with encore's temple spaces as
a case study almost similar to the
adoption of christianity in rome with
admittedly a less pilfered
archaeological record we asked the
question of how religious transition
occurs with established religious
societies and how can we map this
through the archaeological record
the ankorean or khmer empire was a
geopolitical entity which at its peak
encompassed much of thailand laos and
southern vietnam from the 9th century to
the 15th century ce although forms a
single episode within a continuous
uninterrupted cambodian culture and
civilization which have existed since at
least the second millennium bce
the region of encore which is shown on
the right was the beating heart and is
found within a 1 000 square kilometer
area of urban and religious development
including temples monasteries walls
embankments canals road and a massive
infrastructure of undocumented wooden
buildings
this area which is often seen as a
single urban entity is purported to have
been the world's largest pre-industrial
settlement with population estimates
ranging between 750 000 to a million
an essential to understanding encore's
development is the establishment of
indic religion both hinduism and
buddhism in cambodia
these traditions arrived in southeast
asia initially via maritime trade or
overland between the 2nd century
vce and 5th century c and are first
recorded by chinese traders uh who noted
that cambodian policies practiced both
traditions during the at least 5th to
7th century ce
just to back up a moment there are two
schools of buddhism practiced that were
practiced within cambodian history we're
going to leave vajrayana buddhism on the
table for a minute but these are
theravada buddhism and mahayana buddhism
in the simplest terms the major
difference is the latter's focus on
collective enlightenment to the worship
of bodhisattvas or buddhist saints
and the construction of great works
theravada buddhism which is also known
as sinhalese buddhism is derived from
the teachings of the pali canon from the
mahavira monastery in sri lanka
practiced there since the 2nd century
bce which were in turn reinterpreted by
populations in burma and thailand in the
following millennia
this important point emphasizes that
only in scripture are these traditions
similar to what is found in south asia
material southeast asia created
traditions that were tied into
indigenous forms of rulership and
religious practices surrounding the
elements
water which often became a trope
associated with the much later idea of
oriental despotism and ancestral
veneration therefore this process of
hybridization of indie culture and
indigenous rulerships often known as the
indianization of southeast asia based
off the work of the prominent 20th
century epigraphers
and others
important too is that this occurred in
waves it was not a specific event
adopting indig religion and culture and
more often occurred between polities in
southeast asia rather than between south
and southeast asia for example between
thailand and cambodia which was the
spread of theravada buddhism
hindu and buddhist warship which is
known collectively as brahmana buddhism
due to their shared power structures
within cambodia and other southeast
asian polities became a way to validate
and consolidate rule over divided
city-states and princes
southeast asian polities typically
function as centralized theocratic
monarchies ruled by a chakravartin or
universal ruler the king was the wielder
of the dharma or moral law and is often
also incarnated as either hindu deity
shiva or vishnu or a bodhisattva
typically it angkor sheila was the most
commonly venerated deity and the king's
rule was manifested through the worship
of the shiva lena a stone phallus which
combined with the yoni or stimul a
symbol of female fertility would bless
the farmlands and provide a bountiful
harvest
this king provided or presided over a
stratified society of princes vermont
elites cast artisans merchants soldiers
and other skilled laborers and non-caste
agrarian peasants
and it's often touted that only the
elites of any southeast asian polity
practice hinduism although this is
unclear as only a small segment of
society was in fact incorporated within
the verna or caste system
the majority of society was agrarian and
historian david chandler notes that this
caste system divided society between
those who grew rice and those who did
not
within this model scholars have long
read southeast asian religious
landscapes as a direct reflection of
statehood archaeological analyses of
southeast asian statehood have thus
mainly focused on the manufactured
environments constructed by religious
power namely the numerous hindu and
mahayana buddhist state temple complexes
as well as later theravada buddhist
monasteries as our researchers
eliminated as well as their dedicatory
foundation descriptions which were
usually written in sanskrit and temples
across of any size or importance across
the anchoring empire were commonly
established as cosmograms representing
mount meru the home of the 33 gods of
hinduism ruled by lord indra and a
sacred access mundi that represented one
of the 31 plains of existence the
central shrine surrounded by four towers
or peaks of the mountain as you can see
here with nomba king how's the primary
deity either a shiva lingam or a statue
of either vishnu or a buddha
temples would also feature remote over
fronted by a barai known as a reservoir
representing the cosmic ocean and were
surrounded by urban development
including hydrology and perishable
wooden buildings
as also walls
thus these complexes are referred to as
civic ceremonial centers the temple here
nomba king was dedicated in 907 ce by
encore's first regional king yashov in
the first and the area of angkor is
often known as yashodarapura
temples also formed the center of their
own economies
damian evans notes that as microcosms is
the king's capital village shrines and
regional temples across the empire
embody the same political and economic
symbolism as state temples on a smaller
scale and essentially reinforce the
political and social linkages within the
network and through his analysis of
economic transactions found within
epigraphy most notably the inscription
at takeo which is the temple illustrated
here from the 11th century kenneth r
hall surmised that temples controlled
land the labor on the land and the
land's productive output and thus formed
foci of economic systems and political
mechanisms
temples administered the distribution of
resources upheld social structures
through ritual and settlements featured
in indentured labors tied to the temple
known as kun and villages were in fact
tied to temples and administration these
were recorded in many inscriptions for
example at the temple of priya khan
which was constructed in the late 12th
century under the great king jai of arma
vii which administered 5 324 villages
totaling 97 840 people and had an
attached retinue of dancers priests and
temple staff
the civic ceremonial center which will
be the focus of today's talk is on
corton a three by three kilometer walled
and moated citadel constructed in the
late 12th century during the rule of the
great mahayana buddhist king jai of arm
of the seventh as the centerpiece of his
complete re-envisioning and
transformation of the ankorian heartland
hancorton was constructed as a
manifestation of the turning of the
ocean of milkness and in this tale of
indigo mythology the asuras or demons
gained control of heaven forcing king
indra of mount meru into exile and these
demons sought the elixir of immortality
from the cosmic ocean for themselves
vishnu who himself sought to return
indra to his throne implored the divas
or collectively the gods to help the
asuras for a time but promised to keep
the elixir in heaven
in his act seen to balance the universal
forces of good and evil the devas and
asuras began to churn the cosmic ocean
using the nagavasiki as the churning
mechanism
the ashiras chose mount madharachala as
the churning post which would create the
elixir but the mountain began to sink
into the water and vishnu then
transformed the or it transformed into a
turtle one of his many avatars known as
kurma and stabilized the mountain and
one in fact one of the many abhisheka or
coronation rights described on korean
kings was the drinking of the elixir
immortality as a validation kingship
in reference to encore tom's layout the
devas on asuras still align the city's
five gateways holding enormous naga
serpents and the animatic biome temple
which will get you shortly formed mount
mandara although excavations have not
indicated whether there is in fact a
giant turtle under the temple
as a walled urban area angkor thom is
also referred to as a city and is
crisscrossed by an orthogonal road grid
alongside a sophisticated hydraulic
system of canals moats which dictated
the construction of new settlement the
construction of the citadel also
swallowed up ankara's earlier political
hub which was centered on the late 9th
century walled royal palace complex
which is noted as a central zone in the
diagram to the bottom right from which
successive kings continued to rule
the fifth of five arterial roads known
as the victory gate road originally ran
eastward from the royal palace and
linked the complex to the great east
barai constructed by encore's first king
yasho varma the first to get an extent
of the size of this variety 7.8 by 2.1
kilometers large
encore tom is also home
finally to the overwhelming majority of
archaeological evidence for the initial
adoption and dissemination of theravada
buddhism
jayavarman the seventh deserves a bit of
background as his brief subordination of
hinduism for mahayana buddhism is
relevant to our conversation on the
religious transition in the
archaeological record
jayavarman was reportedly converted to
this religion by his first wife prior to
the beginning of his rule and an
enormous collection of inscriptions from
his reign emphasized the bodily ills of
subjects became his spiritual sufferings
the king may therefore have envisioned
himself as an incarnation of either the
bodhisattva
who represented compassion or the
supreme buddha who sat at the nexus of
compassion and wisdom the face towers on
many structures constructed during his
brain as you can see in the bottom right
here
are thought to represent this
overwhelming cult of personality
and in any case jair varman sought to
ease the suffering of the subjects
through the construction of great works
and territorial consolidation and in
commencing the program both the specific
projects in the order in which they were
completed indeed correlate with
architectural styles and building
schemes undertaken during the reign of
earlier hindu monarchs
using the substantial translations of
inscriptions by gerald slides and others
a bigger felix stern was able to map out
a rhythm of three moments of royal
construction across multiple rain
periods and these would comprise first
the foundations of public interest and
the renewal of state authority the
second the completion of an ancestral
temple or temples and third the
establishment of a temple mountain
celebrating the lingam or royal cult
for jai varman's rule the first rhythm
included a vast infrastructural program
including the repaving of the empire's
highways alongside the construction of
rest houses and a whole infrastructure
hospitals and fire shrines associated
with them the second was the
construction of two satellite ceremonial
centers top rome and priya khan
dedicated to his mother and father in
central encore
and the third was a temple mountain of
his own the bayonne temple at the center
of angkor thom this enigmatic temple
which is defined by 54 face towers sits
at the convergence of four of the five
citadel's arterial roads and the temple
again is both an extension of the
churning of the ocean of milk myth as
well as a more traditional incarnation
of mount meru
additionally the bayonne was constructed
as a complex architectural pantheon of
vermont buddhist deities featuring
shrines to buddhas and bodhisattvas
alongside shiva visnu rishi ganesh and
others and it was no doubt the spiritual
heart of jairus vision of empire
creating an umbrella of deities and thus
the hindu elites who worshipped them
which he ruled over
the bayonne would indeed maintain this
position of power at the center of
encore until the abandonment of the
citadel in the 15th century or believed
abandonment and as i'll discuss in a few
slides the bayonne also formed an
important focus for terabyte of buddhist
construction within angkor thom
and as a result of the enormous building
campaign which defined his rule jaya
varma's architectural footprint is
arguably the largest of any unkorian
king but no distinct concorian city
ceremonial centers followed the
foundation of encorton although the
reason for this is disputed
one suggestion by damian evans is that
jai of armand citadel and infrastructure
already encompassed so much of encore's
urban heartland that it no longer made
sense to construct an entirely new
capital from scratch for instance the
creation of a new urban center would
likely require the retooling of any
number of canals within encore's
hydraulic system a move that was likely
unfeasible due to a gradual population
decline and damage to anglers hydrology
forecasts will be done during the 13th
century which was primarily due to
climatic fluctuations and
overexploitation although these are all
topics for another day and a scholar far
more versed in this
the 13th century is also uniquely marked
with the return of the royal cult of
hinduism thought to have been
spearheaded by an intensive campaign of
iconoclasm under the reign of jayagarh
the eighth as you can see here on the on
the right by this hacked out buddha
image at priya khan
and jai of arma the eighth patronage of
hinduism also came with some original
religious construction although not in
the same capacity as the earlier
monarchs and the last day of temple with
angkor the mangalarta dedicated to
vishnu was constructed in 1295 ce
although it's unclear whether mahayana
buddhism was continuously practiced
after this period or whether it was
simply an episode with an encore's
history corresponding with the reign of
jiber in the seventh
[Music]
during the 13th century if not even
during the late 12th a third religion
began to gain a foothold in cambodia in
part due to jayavarman's consolidation
of the western border of its empire
this was theravada buddhism which as i
previously noted is derived from
southeast asia interpretations of
sinhalese buddhism
regionally analyses of the dvarabati
material culture of thailand by scholars
such as stephen murphy suggest that
buddhism was practiced in the region
directly approximate to cambodia at
least by the 6th century ce if not
earlier these duvar vati polities
notably those on the korat plateau of
central east from thailand were almost
always situated on the frontiers of
several larger imperial geobodies for
example the burmese of pagan and the
chimeric encore
the nature of the medieval southeast
asian state is often characterized as a
mandala or cosmic circle and this is
hypothesized by scholars such as stanley
tambien and o.w walters to emplace the
religion of kings in a state of
boundless divine power radiating from a
concentric point across a highly
spiritualized territory which we might
call an empire
in this model the borders of southeast
asian empires
i guess we've called them that
continuously waxed and wayne constantly
emphasizing the center but very little
focus has been given to the cultural
transmission which occurred in this
oft-ignored frontier due to
archaeological and religious nationalism
cementing history within modern borders
although burmese sources indicate that
jai of arma the seventh son tama linda
in fact reportedly visited the
mahavihara with burmese monks in 1180 ce
the first account of theravada buddhist
practice in material culture and encore
comes from the 1296 ce writings of joe
deguan entitled the customs of cambodia
joe was an envoy sent from china by
kublai khan to survey and document the
regions that china saw to be under their
dominion and also possibly because a new
king in jerome iii had been crowned a
year earlier
joe arrived at encore tom and through a
somewhat fragmented perception of
foreign customs and culture observed as
many as three practicing religions
brahmans which he named specifically
worshippers venerating a block of stone
which possibly shiva worshippers and
buddhists whose monks wore saffron robes
and worship large images of the buddha
and roofed halls the first mention of
any structure resembling what we found
in the archaeological record
joe also importantly notes that every
family practiced buddhism which suggests
that the construction of the mangalarta
a year earlier was the product of just
one of the traditions of practice being
or being practiced in encore rather than
some overnight flick of the switch as it
somewhat suggested an earlier
scholarship it's likely that theravada
had been there for a time
the king in jabarin iii was also a
practicing buddhist and joe notes
generally when leaving and returning to
the palace he had to visit a small gold
pagoda with a buddha in front of it
unlurkers all had to kneel down and
touch their head on the ground
theravada buddhist practice after this
point is thought to have gradually
gained ground on the remaining hindu
traditions as a religion widely
practiced across all social classes and
while hierarchy indeed continue to exist
within the rituals performed and
practiced in monasteries rulership
appears to be less tied to connection
with hindu deities the epigraphic
language in fact shifted from sanskrit
to pali the canon language of similes
buddhism in the 14th century and an
inscription exists from 1309 ce at
coxified czech temple in northwestern
cambodia which describes the king's
abdication for the life of the biku or
monk which seems unprecedented the king
would typically have died in his
position if he wasn't overthrown or
killed
the last inscription dedicated to shiva
appears on the bayonne from 1327 ce
which is noteworthy as much for its
dedication to a hindu king as its
inscription on a monument which may have
kept its significance as a pantheon but
certainly remained emblematic of loyal
authority
[Music]
theravada buddhism also introduced a new
material culture comprising of new
religious and monastic spaces called
vihara or prayer halls which are derived
likely derived from those found within
buddhist polities in northern thailand
such as sukhothai which was established
in the 13th century or the dvarabati
parties which had a mine which
by the excavation of several boundary
stones
in kulin may have had a minor
presence in cambodia
archaeologists refer to these distinct
edifices at encore as either buddhist
terrorists a translation of the french
classifier
or preview here the trend translation of
vihara the distinction though is that
buddhist terrorists comprise the
archaeological substructural remains and
pravihir represent the edifice in which
buddhist rites were performed
like temples the floor plan of a
buddhist terrace
buddhist terrorists shown here with the
example of angkor thom v here or atp 7
was to a degree standardized that said
it's currently impossible to determine
the entire structure because the wooden
superstructure which could have made up
up to 90 of the building has in all
cases disintegrated due to cambodia's
jungle climate although from comparisons
with roof structures depicted and
released on temples they were likely a
little different than monastic
structures found in cambodia today
in any case almost all of these
structures faced east derived from the
positioning of temples in reference to
shiva and vocalized a single colossal
buddha on a
statue on a raised stone plinth at the
western extremity
above the wooden superstructure the
edifice would have been typically topped
with a tiled roof the use of roof tiles
is significant because joe deguan
explicitly describes sanctuary laws
associated with using tile only in elite
or royal buildings which puts these
buildings potentially under royal
patronage in german iii for example is
known to have dedicated land for preview
construction and from the 1309
inscription previously noted so this
indicates that the king's land i.e all
land was donated by the court to the
sangha or monastic order to build a
local monastery
the most significant ritual delineator
of pravihir space are sema a series of
blessed stone orbs or other stone
deposits used to demarcate ordination
spaces with a theravada monastery encore
monastic communities adopted the earlier
vati tradition of erecting prominent
stone markers or sema stones over these
deposits in an eight by one or eight by
two formation at the cardinal and
sub-cardinal boundaries of each probably
here
sema in fact have been the single most
consistent variable and classifier of
these former preview hair sites during
survey and showed significant variation
in both style and craftsmanship in turn
the placement of cms surrounding vihara
is unique within theravada practice in
southeast asia as these buildings would
typically be separated into a vihara and
uposathegara or ordination hall and may
represent a uniquely anchorian
focalization of tarabata ritual space
which might be argued to descend from
the centralization
of humidity and ritual on a single
structure existent in hindu practice
highlighted amongst the supporting
infrastructure of walls causeways and
minor image houses known as salah a
select number of buddhist terrorist
complexes feature reliquary monuments of
varying sizes for more familiarity
familiarly known as stupas which either
stand as a separate structure or are
directly attached to the main complex
reliquaries serve as repositories of
statuary treasure and funerary remains
and if present appear directly west of
the bravi here on an axe field
trajectory with both the central
sanctuary and eastern el sima
based on the substructural remains two
main reliquary forms existed at encore
the first is known as apratia and
resembles a small temple tower with this
almost entirely unique to encore while
more traditional bell-shaped reliquaries
locally known as chitty were introduced
later in the 14th or even 15th century
arguably as a product of growing thai
influence on encore and architecture
in the lower right corner or lower left
corner you can actually see a possible
indication of the superposition between
these two types of structures
which is important to remember when we
discussed temporal conversions
corresponding with terabyta buddha's
perceptions of temple space as well as
how it evolved
and on the right there are as evidence
there are smaller funerary stupas that
surround more prominent buddhist terror
structures this one surrounds the
buddhist terrorists by the biome temple
the lidar map illustrates the current
known extent of encore tom's mass
development and comprises buddhist
terrorists with and without seema stones
although we found so many as votive
deposits at the foot of central
sanctuary pedestals that's very likely
many were excavated from their original
positions during later periods this
amounts to 72 gravi here within a nine
square kilometer area and while i think
this number might be slightly low
the 13 identified with temples and
infrastructure in central encore is
definitely understated and requires
further investigation
still this number represents a massive
building campaign centered on our corton
which through radiometric dating we've
determined likely primarily occurred
during the 14th century if not slightly
earlier
we're currently exploring the
possibility of a purposeful monastic
construction boom during this period but
this theory requires far more excavation
my methodology in mapping these
structures required the use of colonial
french hand-drawn maps from the early
20th century overlaid with modern lidar
collected by the greater iron core
project and absurd authority and then
two years of ground survey and catalog
thanks to this effort appsera granted us
permission to excavate test fits across
several sites across add-on corton which
became the basis of our collaborative
encore bihar project the results and
observations i've presented thus far and
will present are based on four seasons
of field work within this region with at
least two more still to come
and just to give you a sense of the
range of dates associated with buddhist
terrorist habitation which come from
three of our four excavation sites
spread across encore tom as well as the
context in which some of these charcoal
samples we dated come from for example
on the bottom or left to this uh one
charcoal sample came between two from
between two avian bones underneath the
hand of a foot long earth touching
buddha at the site of pravier's
dismantled central sanctuary or another
came from the base of the buddhist
terror staircase that we had excavated
into
these of course are not the only dates
we gathered which included several
stratigraphic samples dating from the
11th to 12th centuries this suggests
that many buddhist parasites were in
fact constructed in areas of previous
occupation either residential or even
religious based on the excavation of
upper on the upper right a votive
deposit of a single rounded gypsum stone
dated from this earlier period
this was the date associated
although pravi hair collectively formed
the most common theravada buddhist place
of worship found within encore and
clearly formed anchors of religious
transition and community rarely are
these edifices given the same religious
social or political agencies the temples
which preceded them this is odd
considering the focality of the modern
watt in cambodia and cambodian daily
life
olivia de barano was one of the first
few one of the first scholars who was
served at this agency
through likely through his comparison
with both contemporary trans-regional
and modern cambodian examples whereby in
his view monastery serves as the grounds
for internment of the dead through the
construction of stupas and reliquaries
for resource distribution many featured
treasuries and also served as
repositories for donations or of
offerings which are typically given in
the form of statues gold or alms of food
and insects
pravi here are also believed to have had
a population of indentured laborers tied
to the monastery possibly villages and
likely functioned as anchors of local or
regional economies in a similar manner
to hall's model although of course this
is thus far entirely
undocumented my own research which
through archaeological analysis has
indeed verified many of de barinol's
observations has sought to explore and
explain the diversity of architecture
within the uniform floor plan i would
this thus acknowledge the possibility
that the dissemination of buddhism was
local rather than centralized despite
land being donated by the king
this might help explain the size of ravi
here the types and qualities of
materials used
our main uh diacritic is quarried
sandstone which would come from a quarry
in the coolant hills to the north
northeast versus recycled sandstone
which likely came from a dismantled
temple as well as the craftsmanship of
associated statuary and sema
the number of exiting statue pedestals
the number of luxury goods most notably
chinese export wares gold leaf ornaments
and green glazed khmer cylidon boxes and
the number of funerary and relatory
monuments associated with each complex
varying access to resources and artistry
by monastic populations indeed may have
been a product of local social status
the wealthier patrons and most families
were the more extravagant your prayer
hall may have been
these ideas run in sharp contrast to the
ways oncorian scholars previously
interpreted the original material output
and development of theravada in cambodia
in fact prayer halls and other monastic
structures are often omitted from
discussions of theravada buddhist
development in encore entirely often
relegated as secondary and thus
unimportant monuments
prior to radiometric analysis buddhist
monuments such as these were thought to
generally date from the 15th and 19th
century products of a superficial epoch
known as the boston korean or middle
period which was framed as the cambodian
dark age following the disputed fall of
encore in 1431 and preceding the
establishment of the colonial french
protectorate in 1863 a very romanticized
narrative
encoring scholars focused on temples and
inscriptions saw an absence of these two
major cultural staples temples and
descriptions as a reflection of encore's
decline and a breakdown of its political
order and most notably important for the
early colonial french grandeur
conversely a select number of buddhist
scholars influenced by the late 19th and
20th century buddhist nationalist
movements across southeast asia
corresponding with independence
interpreted anchoring theravada as
almost a revolution against the more
tyrannical hindu and mahayana buddhist
state structures and painted theravada
as a sort of buddhist utopia especially
in reference to the contemporary thai
buddhist kingdom sukkot
and while there's certainly some
validity to the idea that theravada
warship transcended social classes in a
way hindu cast may have not as well as
the ease at which of which members of
late classes could be indoctrinated as
monks thus dividing or thus coming
bringing together those who grew united
rice and those who did not
it's very unlikely any sort of social
revolution occurred as society remained
stringently hierarchical and most
importantly stable
but if materiality and landscape
analysis remain the focus of
investigations to answer these questions
about korean religion the study of
architecture and the surrounding urban
settlement of monasteries are especially
important to understanding the dynamics
of a period from which inscriptions are
no longer accident yet construction is
continuing
for example in reference to the notion
of mandala discussed earlier the
correlation of psi shown here indirectly
replicates the locality of the cosmic
center of ankortom including its
arterial roads with a peripheral
boundary of smaller structures
each structure and complex likely
fulfilled the same ritual functions but
evidently those structures near the
center had the capacity to host larger
congregations and feature elegantly
carved likely quarried sandstone
substructures a picture for
savaros poo for example suggested that
monks may have been ordained at more
prominent pravihir complexes and built
their own prayer halls where they lived
with the resources at their disposal and
their preview similar to temples served
as satellites of political religious
authority for the regions in which they
were constructed
the use of recycled stone to build these
smaller structures on the periphery is
notably abundant as well stressing the
inequality between monastic populations
also key to upholding political
religious authority across the anchoring
empire was the standardized replication
of a central religious sanctuary one
which in our understanding of mandala
unified the elites of the state under a
common worldview and thus an imperial
rule which strengthened the periphery of
the state in relation to the center
although no evidence has thus far been
identified to suggest a central monastic
hub within encore the great monastery of
tepranom encore's largest buddhist
terrorist complex is the most probable
candidate to have fulfilled this rule
based on existing archaeological
evidence
tepronom which is found directly north
of the royal palace was continuously
expanded by unknown factions under
unknown monarchs and no inscription
exists to dedicate its initial
foundation
however an inscription was found there
in 19 or 1908 that had been moved from a
buddhist ashram dedicated by the 9th
century king yasho varma in the first at
least five centuries earlier and
teprenom was actually thought to be the
site of an early hindu with the hindu
building
the same inscription and its
accompanying ashram was also rededicated
by the 11th century king suryavarma the
first who despite constructing a temple
mountain was a buddhist
this feeli clearly was moved with
purpose as other foundation steelies
unrelated to buddhas entirely have been
found at other buddhist terrorist
complexes as deposits
and potentially signified tepranom as an
established royal sanctuary the actual
ashram which was identified fully um in
the early 2000s is found more than four
miles away and does not appear to have
been used since its 11th century
rededication
visually if correct and of course we
need to excavate more to establish the
specifics there appears to be a clear
aim by encore's buddhist populations and
rulers to ensure a smooth transition
between past and present principles of
religious space
but how did ankurian populations deal
with the overwhelming number of hindu
and mahayana buddhist temples in their
midst
close to five centuries of temple
mountains are found within the capital
central zone still and it's not yet
clear whether any temples were
demolished to build buildings or build
monastic buildings despite the abundant
use of recycled sandstone but the
original temple space as a cella holding
a lingam no longer exists at any of
these temples
so how were these places reconciled with
a new built environment especially since
a large number of the temples were in
fact converted
well first as jodaguan described a
period of religious pluralism followed
both jai of army aids hindu iconoclasm
and the institutionalization of
theravada in the late 13th century so
this may have not even been an issue
until the 14th which marks the point
when many probably here were inhabited
if not constructed but as pravihir space
began to become the predominant area of
worship in hindu practice
and our worship and hindu practices were
slowly phased out rather than the
pronoun rather than demolishing these
temples they were transformed or
negotiated
live space or edward soja's third space
provide key theoretical frameworks for
understanding the types of processes
embedded within converted temples and
how conversions changed over time based
on the perception of ancient monuments
i also want to importantly acknowledge
that this research from an
anthropological perspective was first
undertaken by dr ashley thompson from
soas whose work was an important
inspiration for my own
one major indicator that temples were
converted was the installation of a
prescribed iconography likely imported
from contemporary thai buddhist imagery
which is found represented in both
standing statuary and release
each image intentionally depicts a
specific episode from the life of the
buddha the parana image on the lower
left for example illustrates the buddha
breaking the life cycle and passing into
nirvana after his death whereas the
earth touching buddha
in the both on the right
is constructed in reference to buddha's
defeat of the demon mara asking the
earth to witness his victory through
touch
these images are almost almost constant
always constant across converted temples
and are far more uniform than hindu and
mahayana buddhist iconography which
primarily owes to the centuries of local
artistic development within encore
rather than just their import
it's also probable that buddhist
terrorism inverted temples were
initially collectively standardized in
their layout and temples such as
preyapalilai and western present top
thus may represent the first type of
conversions found in encore the latter's
conversion or at least its new southern
tower
based on the diagram here
has in fact been hypothesized to date
from the late 13th century based on
radiometric analysis by nara who are
currently undertaking anastylosis at the
temple
this was based may have been based on
continued sacredness ascribed to the
inner sanctuary in order to standardize
these monuments which is thought to have
been converted into a reliquary in both
cases
the placement of a property here
fronting the temple and either the
replication or origin of this alignment
between buddhist terraces and
reliquaries which is kind of a chicken
and egg situation
especially through the installation of
the practice reliquary shows that there
was an attempt to create uniform on
korean terabyte of space regardless of
the edifice
also important to note with these
initial temple conversions for their
confinement to smaller structures not
the enormous state temples
these if they were transformed were
subject to much larger renovations and
either blocking up or the overall
demolition of their mount meru towers
at least one of these temples the 11th
century batpoon on the right
was physically transformed during the
15th century into a 65 meter statue
of a reclining buddha apparent nirvana
at the expense of its central sanctuary
which is known from carbon dates taken
from iron
crampons embedded within the buddha
in a similar manner encore's first
temple mountain and king was physically
transformed into a statue of the seated
buddha similarly through the demolition
of its towers but research on this
installation is impossible as early
french conservators saw it as an eyesore
and demolished it to reconstruct the
original mount meru in the 1920s
and this image illustrates it's also
possible that many pratya once
accessible were blocked up or
transformed into closed reliquaries
during this period archival photographs
show that this was not a modern
renovation in the red box here
the construction of reliquaries and
temple architecture as well as the tempo
of temple conversions moving from
accessible to closed are ideas i hope to
investigate in future excavation season
and encore as we create a better idea of
when the central hindu temple space was
not only abandoned but seen as
negligible or even negatively charged
the placement of buddhist terrorists has
thus far been proven to be rarely
arbitrary as i previously indicated in
our excavations have unearthed
radiometric artifactual structural and
even votive remains associated with
earlier domestic or religious dwellings
on the same site
however the most unique patterns of
crappy here occur in relation to temples
as well as arterial roads based on
connections to these elements i refer to
these alignments as foci of memory as a
working hypothesis whereby memory refers
to continued significance and reverence
for ancient things over time and the
reckoning of the past the populations
undertook when establishing their
futures across multi-temporal landscapes
working with our data i've established a
few important caveats for each focus
each appears to honor and re-legitimize
or reify a brahmana buddhist sanctuary
within its place in the landscape which
in turn reinforced and legitimated the
original layout of our tom its roadways
and its individual monuments
renovations are all and conversions are
also common amongst temples that anchor
foci
the key concept as well number two is
old infrastructure and new property here
found within each focus embody a
reciprocal relationship whereby neither
is sacred within the therapeutic of
their terabyte of buddhist landscape
without the other
third what is found in ancorton is the
culmination of each focus and it is
unknown whether these areas were
developed gradually or immediately
however none of them
none of the foci are found in any
epigraphic records and are inferred
through analysis of map data and thus
the flexibility of this heuristic
enables additional interpretation so
this is just a hypothesis but it seems
to have some spatial relevance
the biome for example formed a focal
point of a concentric layout of buddhist
terraces none of which are identical
this suggests that this focus was
created gradually rather than as a
single act of construction and that
monasteries in the focus were not
created by a single faction but several
over time
still by coincidence or by some
continuous perception of the biome the
layout today resembles a mandala
surrounding the temple and clearly
cements the bayonne as the continuous
pivot of the citadel
another example is found in the form of
a staggered line of buddhist terrorists
spanning the entire longitudinal
thoroughfare of ankortong only
interrupted by the central zone which
during survey we called the north south
gate road zigzag
interestingly joe deguan attributes some
significance to at least the southern
portion of this route in his writings as
you can see in the quote in the bottom
right
this thoroughfare ultra features a large
number of structures with fire brick
remains bricks interestingly had not
been used
on mass and oncorian architecture since
the late 10th early 11th centuries when
they were replaced almost entirely by a
combination of sandstone and laterite
and it's therefore likely bricks were
reintroduced to oncorian architecture by
means of expanding thai influence where
brick and plaster construction during
this period are abundant
additionally brick renovations appear on
top of sandstone and laterite so it's
likely that this was a later
installation
we excavated one of the structures along
the route and like other pravi here
across the citadel we dated a bone
deposit near the central sanctuary to
the 14th century
according to contemporary thai sources
encore was successfully attacked in 1431
by armies from the thai kingdom of
ayutia ayutiya the buddhists embodied
the same rigid social hierarchy
standardized replication of architecture
divine rulership rights and even the
idea of constructing a temple mountain
at their island capital north north of
bangkok as within hindu encore and the
geopolitical expansion of ayutia between
the 14th and 15th centuries is thought
to have been a major cause of the
decommission of encore as the capital of
cambodia while cambodia's ruling class
left the region for a series of capitals
surrounding modern phnom penh over the
ensuing three centuries
scholars such as michael vickery
highlight the possibility that
a ut and prince occupied on corton at
some point during the mid 15th century
but for all intents and purposes the old
citadel was no longer a significant
civic ceremonial center encore 2 was now
positioned squarely on cambodia's
frontier
radiometric dates
found across on corton including from
our own research indicate the
possibility of a 15th century upper
limit of occupation and course taken
from the encore tom moat by dan penny's
team from the university of sydney
suggest overall hydraulic neglect during
this period which he describes as
swamp-like
seriations of chinese ceramics
undertaken by iodara david brotherson
and others
show an absence of bing dynasty that is
late 14th to 15th century blue and white
chinese export wares at pravihir sites
as opposed to song dynasty 11th to 14th
century as well as yuan dynasty
cylidon and white wares which indicate a
relative lack of habitation or votive
activities beyond the 15th century
the great temple of angkor wat to the
south meanwhile was transformed into a
prominent
pilgrimage site during the 16th century
this conversion may have in fact
occurred earlier as two buddhist
terrorists were constructed there which
according to cambodian royal chronicles
date from the years following encore's
defeat by ayutia
encore watt was originally constructed
by king siribarman second during the
early to mid 12th century as a shrine of
vishnu and holds the recognition as the
world's largest religious monument
the temple is known especially for its
1.6 kilometers of release including an
earlier illustration of the churning of
the ocean milk
an activity at the temple is documented
in an expansive volume of inscriptions
in the khmer language dating from 1546
ce onwards and was continuously
patronized by the royal family who
walled up the old central sanctuary of
the central most tower with buddha
freezes decommissioning the earlier
vision of cella
while a less destructive act than the
baboon or non-vacant re-envisioning this
blocking of space clearly reflects
similar perceptions of earlier temple
sanctuaries either as either defunct or
dangerous
inscriptions too clearly engage with
memory venerating the august ancestors
and encore's previous kings
to conclude
the landscape of buddhist terrorism here
illustrates a unique and localized
adoption of theravada buddhism and
cortana and central encore one which was
required to negotiate the built
environment of institutionalized
political religious authority but also
propagate this new religious practice in
a unique framework which would guarantee
its success
theravada at encore i contend was
manifested nowhere else the same in
southeast asia
the construction and placement of these
new structures honored earlier material
and spatial ritual traditions
highlighting the importance of core
periphery relations and religious place
making while also serving as an
innovative advancement which cemented
pravihir as familiar religious
architectures
the incorporation of hindu and mahayana
buddhist infrastructure into theravada
buddha's understandings of place was
also indeed an evolving process although
more research is necessary to understand
any of these theoretical avenues
and finally encore tom serves as a
fascinating and important case study for
religious transition in the
archaeological record one which unlike
more prominent civic ceremonial centers
such as rome athens or even sukhothai
which was once itself a town on the
khmer frontier contains a relatively
undisturbed archaeological record where
the idealization of history and search
for origins did not come at the expense
of the site's more recent history which
is aside from that poor little buddha
non-bakken
ideas of social memory indigenous time
continuity rather than the phasing and
epochalization of history and even
modern perception of these sacred sites
by local worshipers can easily and
accurately be analyzed here with local
collaboration prioritization of
cambodian academic goals and honoring of
ancor's everlastingly spiritually
charged nature being paramount to all
successful future research
and these are just some of our goals for
the upcoming two field seasons in 2022
as well as one possibly in 2023
and i'd love to hear your questions
again it's been an honor to present for
all of you at center for southeast asian
studies and thank you
thank you so much andrew this is uh
really a rich presentation i think we'll
have a lot of
questions here um so what i'd like to do
is open it up to the audience
andrew maybe you can stop the screen
share but we may ask you to pull up some
images later but you seem to be pretty
good at going back and forth between so
we can see the faces of people asking
questions so if anyone has a question i
suggest you use the um raise hand
function of zoom and then i'll call on
you and i'll keep a list as they start
appearing to try to get an order to our
questions
um so i'll wait for a moment as people
collect their thoughts and i look
forward to hearing from you
um so we'll start with eric white um
eric go ahead
hi hi andrew thank you for the the talk
so i'm not
a specialist of cambodia or cambodian
buddhism okay i work on
contemporary thai
thailand thai buddhism so my question is
more comparative
sort of builds off of your some of your
closing comments
and it's
and the
you know it's said in this i'm often
concerned that there's there is an over
emphasis on the similarities right of
tibetan buddhist cultures and histories
across the region uh
you know they all rather than thinking
about
multiple teravata buddhisms in the
region there's often a kind of
a tendency to
to sort of uh
conflate uh beliefs and practices
literary material culture sometimes so
in that light you know
how
how do you see the character and
dynamics of the
introduction
and consolidation of tarabata buddhism
in cambodia
uh differing
from dynamics
uh
of the introduction of tarabata buddhism
in other
regions right or other polities in this
in this pre-modern era you know
you sort of mentioned
you gestured towards these unique local
character and i'm wondering if you could
actually you know for uh
if you could sort of itemize even you
know just list out what you saw
what you see is uniquely in terms of the
character and dynamics and um
and especially if you see them having
enduring significance for the
for the character of cambodian buddhism
and later period right so thinking about
essentially path dependencies the way
that
initial differences have had enduring
consequences
that's a that's a great question i think
i think coming from my perspective which
is more archaeological and ecological i
can't necessarily talk to the rights and
rituals involved the inscriptions are
lacking it's not quite clear how
buddhism was first practiced and we like
to talk about sinhalese buddhism but
again you just can't say that
with encore what we're finding in the
archaeological record is it is is a
discerning attempt
to
create a worldview that makes sense to
the people in the hierarchies that exist
the idea that religious dissemination is
successful
not based on chaos but based on
continuity is something that we're
seeing within the unkorian
archaeological record the idea that
and this is these are things that i had
to take out otherwise the presentation
has been hours but
uh the architecture itself in many of
the late 13th early 14th century
structures is not recycled it's quarried
and it's carved in a way that almost is
identical to the way that one would
enter a temple you see buddhist
terrorism with balustrades and sing
alliance that are easily recognizable
you see the idea that the sanctuaries
always has is faced eastward and the
only time it hadn't in young korean
history was when the temple was
dedicated to vishnu
and so there seems to be this idea that
buddhism at encore is unique because of
not necessarily hinduism not necessarily
what was practiced before in terms of
religious practice but the space itself
the the idea that this is what we know
as a as a place of worship the pratya is
the temple it's not it's not a question
of
uh it's not a question of
how is are we going to include the
temple it's where does the temple go
it's not even a thought it's where does
the temple go and over time as i
mentioned as ayutian uh traditions
become stronger and geopolitically
become more dominant in the region you
do see this shift towards a more
a more time not necessarily religious
version but material version of buddhism
which is again an incredibly
controversial point in the 20th and 21st
century but at the same time um there's
a cambod there is you're right a
uniquely cambodian tradition uniquely
thai tradition which admittedly comes
mostly from the 20th century when the
french
essentially did not allow cambodian
monks to travel to thailand they said
you cannot be indoctrinated here we're
going to create our own school and this
is
the way to make sure that our territory
is consolidated within cambodia is to
break that so the tradition has been
much more modern than ancient and so
within early theravada it's much easier
to tell a distinct distinct difference
between regions and what was adopted
and i think maybe that gives us some
maybe that's a somewhat meandering uh
answer to your question but i i think i
would stand by the idea that this was as
i say localized based on what people
knew of religious space
thanks no problem
andrew well we're waiting for other
questions um
i want to ask you
a question about spatial location versus
spatial orientation okay and i i just
made this idea up so it may be totally
unusual or
strange
but
i would as i was listening to
throughout the talk and then hearing
your response to eric's question as well
you were noting the importance of a kind
of recognition of a particular religious
space of worship so in a sense it's a
kind of location right there's a spot on
the map in a sense that seems to have
accrued meaning as a place of religious
practice or worship or something and
there's actually a kind of
historical
uh respect for that and actually a
reproduction of that space even if
there's a shift in the actual spatial
practice that happens in that space
right
and then but as you're answering that
you also said well you can really see
like when it faces east you know that
never happened before until this
this orientation comes along right and
so i'm curious if there's ways in the
map
rec so the location is the same but the
orientation is turned and i'm wondering
if there's ways in your mapping practice
that you can
systematically notice that and tied to
this is just another question that i had
was um
as you were talking about the um
the kind of respect for a previous
religious practice that had placed even
if there's a religious transformation
that happens
that struck me as very interesting in
comparison to one little example he
showed where there was the smashed out
buddha image yeah i think it was from
the 13th century right which is clearly
not a respect of the previous practice
but it's still in the same place um so
that's i'm just wondering if you could
play with that idea of orientation
versus location sure um
what i actually had said about the
orientation of buddhist terrorists was
they faced east which was not a shift it
was actually something that made them
similar to shiva temples it was
something that that they'd face east
which is a direction derived from in
reverence to indra
and in terms of the iconography the
iconoclasm
it was actually something that
when i was writing my thesis i toyed
around with as an earlier re-envisioning
of the ancorian landscape
mahayana buddhism
was something that was revolutionary and
new and tied to a king maybe one or two
kings it's not quite clear whether
jaibarman's successor injured the second
was a mahayana buddhist but
it was a sense that these sanctuaries
could be used
could be reinterpreted all they needed
was the images gone jaya barman gone and
they were still perfectly good
sanctuaries
they still were recognizable they were
still oriented in a way that was
understandable they still housed
populations they still housed laborers
and were were the foci of a polit
political and economic systems that they
were before
so it's it's an interesting it's an
interesting idea to say the least and i
think there there actually has been a
good amount of work
done on the architecture itself but not
necessarily on
what types of things iconoclasm and what
types of asp what happens when an image
gets hacked out of a temple or gets
transformed there are actually several
that were buddhas were transformed into
lingams and into rishis or saints
and so
what does that mean
and how do we how do we look more at
that because the way that encore in
history is often constructed is that it
there's periods of boom and bust
continuously boom bust boom bust and
this one was a dramatic event and every
time a king returned to some sort of
royal cult
every single time there's always
violence there's always thought to be
violence
iconoclasm is a violent act in itself
but it's but it's not clear from the
13th century although jadaguan mentions
a war with sukhothai that the ankurian
kingdom
was in any sort of tumult
climatological issues aside
so i would like to i really would like
to explore more about the iconoclasm of
hinduism so it's um
yeah it's it's it's something to
investigate further i think
again
again another meandering answer to your
question
can i ask just a brief
technical follow-up question that may be
obvious to all the archaeologists in the
room but how does one d i can understand
how one might date
existing objects but how does one date
when something was destroyed
like for example the hacking away of a
buddha face it removes the material so
what kind of how does one actually date
them they don't and that's part of
that's part of sort of
it adds up and so deductive reasoning is
used there's two theories on the
iconoclasm one that had occurred during
the reign of jive army and the second is
in a sort of a newer reaction is that it
occurred during the reign of
uh
parameshvira who was the last hindu king
and according to the cambodian royal
chronicles he was in fact assassinated
by his gardener so there was theravada
buddhist kings after that so those are
kind of the two ideas
and
through archaeology you unless there's
residue on an axe you really can't do it
it's it's all it's all speculative
you have to hope more epigraphy comes up
um i see a hand up from word keeler and
ben has appeared on video so i'll call
on ward keeler first and then turn to
ben after that go ahead
thanks i um
work in burma and indonesia so cambodia
is really quite foreign to me but i
wonder if um
a pattern that seems discernible all
over southeast asia doesn't help your
explanation
that is to say that any sight can be
can be seen
to be a residue of enormous amounts of
power
of
spiritual power whatever you want to
call it it's just there's a node of
power there that is available to be
tapped
so of course you would want to keep the
place because these places are imbued
with that kind of power
at the same time every religious reform
movement
is a way for those
in power
to
divert more power to themselves to make
a break with the past to show some sort
of new direction that enables them to do
things like you know what happens in
burmese history is that
all the monks have to
uh be re-uh
re-initiated which means a completely
new order to the to the hierarchy so
i just wonder if that makes sense as a
way of putting together different parts
of what you have uh described
fully 100 and that's that's what's
missing from the equation is really any
any royal record of what's going on at
encore you don't know why theravada
buddhism seeked in people have painted
it as a social revolution which is
something that i've disputed um
and it's
the continuities we see in the
archaeological record
indeed reflect the idea that power is
consolidated and spaces remain sacred
again why
why not build something familiar if
you're working with familiar power so i
fully agree with that
andrew thanks very much for a very
informative and uh
uh fascinating and revealing
presentation a lot of it was new to me
and i learned a lot from it
um i wonder if you would agree that
we're talking about a major
transformation in cambodian society here
uh
not just a religious transformation but
political and social transformation as
well in the
14th and 15th centuries
and
where
i wonder if you'd like to comment on
some of the traditional explanations for
that
transformation or those transformations
and and and how your explanation and
your observations fit in to these sort
of more long-standing or traditional uh
explanations you know one of them
that's been around for a long time is
that joey obama vii who who built uncle
corton
with his 40-year
reign
and massive building program just
exhausted the cambodian population
and led to you know a major
change in the in the popular
uh image of of uh centralized a
centralized empire and kingdom and moved
to a more village-oriented
uh terravada buddhist uh society away
from a hindu and mahayana buddhist
society but
there are two other more recent
explanations which might
i'd be interested to hear your comments
on
one of them is that it was a change in
uh world trade patterns that uh the
world trade going past the south china
sea uh
made the option very attractive for the
uh and korean elites to move further
south down the river to be closer to the
south china sea trade and and angkor was
abandoned basically for
uh an an inland agrarian society changed
to a maritime commercial society
uh and that that may be something uh
that the terabyte of buddhism and its
adoption broadly across cambodia had
something to do with that uh economic
change uh
and then
we have the
climate explanation as well
uh the you know the 1300s uh were
basically the the end of the
medieval warm period it became much less
uh wet a lot drier and more frequent
droughts in the late 1300s and early
1400s does that have anything to do with
the transformation that you're
uh talking about and and and finally
just a quick question related to what
you're talking about that i i just
wonder whether
the
uh dominance enjoyable in the seventh
reign
of mahayana buddhism which was unusual
for
compared to previous and korean monarchs
even though
mahayana buddhism was part of the
religious structure along with hinduism
but the unusual predominance of mahayana
buddhism was that in a way a kind of
transitional
phase towards a new kind of
uh terribles and a terabyte of buddhist
transition that was made
possible
rather than precipitated as another
explanation might have it
by by joe obama in the seventh round
so as we know in the 1300 or in the in
the 1200s right after the death of jaya
brahma the seventh
the encore got rocked by
event after event after event
first mega monsoons and mega droughts
almost is are believed to have begun to
decimate the hydraul the hydrology of
anchoring and greater ancor most notably
during that period
then you have the hypotheses of
depopulation of
uh plague of just of expansion from
other qualities sukhothai and sukhothai
and ut has successively uh
got or successfully expanded during this
period
so
in terms of theravada buddhism even
though these things seem to correlate
jai varma exploited the resources of the
capital um as as lawrence briggs wrote
the command the khmer got licked
by religion or something that quote um
but it's very it's very hard and
just not wise quite yet to connect
theravada buddhism and the so and any
sort of social upheaval to those events
they seem to make sense
but again i'd like to see i just as an
archaeologist i'd like to see the
connection between monastic construction
and any type of climatological
fluctuation
uh in more than just more than just
circumstantial events happening around
the same time it's it it's a very
logical explanation but again
dangerous without more evidence on my
part at least
in terms of trade
um
there was i mean
there's there's theories that
the focus moved to the mekong delta
before the traditional sacrifice for the
i mean it was a logical place
based on the trade wealth in the south
china sea that was coming in and we i
mentioned as i mentioned um we do have
evidence of an upper limit potentially
at buddhist terraces on corton based on
those chinese ceramic seriations the
idea that there have not been any blue
and whites found although there have
been blue and whites found out in angkor
wat by allison carter's team or down by
a by gap
so there's none up here yet and you know
there might be you do another excavation
another site you might find some later
occupation we're not finding that yet
um in terms of
jaya varman and the
uh introduction of teravata by way of
mayana
i think as i mentioned that has more to
do with
the activity and consolidation of the
frontier or the western frontier where
theravada buddhism was being practiced
around areas like pima you do have
populations that are that are buddhist
and had been for a while siri of arm and
the second or the first is thought to
have been from pima the architect of
bachcham uh
under regeneron was thought to be from
pmi
and you might just simply have more
engagement on that cultural frontier
than you otherwise would have in the
past based on on the repaving and
restructuring of the roads and so that
creates a floodgate as well as if
populations were being absorbed under
that under that hegemony again
speculative
and needs more archaeology needs more
cooperative archaeology and that's why i
hesitate to construct a narrative beyond
what we know from joe diguan onwards
thank you
very good
thank you andrew we have another
question from louise court louise if you
can uh ask your questions
uh i'm sorry i can't turn on my camera
it seems to be broken not a problem nice
to meet you going to go from
really broad and fascinating questions
to a very my new point that you made in
passing and through
my attention
as someone interested in the development
of ceramic production in the encore
region
um you mentioned
showing a group of chinese shards
there were also finds and i believe it
was
from the excavation of one of the
buddhist terraces
of the kinds of green glazed or celadon
glazed lidded boxes that were a major
product of the kiln on top of kulen
yes and i talked to ia darath about that
he was he was very happy about that that
we were finding we only found them at
two sites
um one of which was
uh our major excavation site where we
found more than a couple of shares and
the other one was a site that was
surrounded by the remains of an
acropolis and those shirts were actually
associated with the base stupa so they
may have been
considered luxury goods in that
perspective
but um
the production of covered boxes like
that goes back
to a point earlier than
the date you've been giving for the
introduction of theravada
by several centuries and so
i'm wondering whether this is a
very microscale
example of how um production of a
certain kind of object within the
encorian material culture could be
shifted in use from
some kind of offering
equipment for a hindu context into a
theravada buddhist context
sure um
i was actually thinking about this one
right after we excavated the boxes and
there's kind of two ways you can think
about it the first is that it those
boxes were considered ancient goods and
were considered and were given as votive
deposits and then thus are kind of
anachronistic
uh the other is that
they were
from an earlier era of occupation on the
same site
on three of the four sites that we
excavated we found uh
we found ceramic offerings
or not ceramic offerings ceramic remains
that dated from an earlier period as
sort of related to the stratigraphy of
our radiocarbon dates and so there is a
thought that
at least in one of at least with the
site with the gypsum foundation stone we
found which was actually surrounded by
bones and charcoal
that you might have
the site of an earlier religious
occupation and then a that gives you
more sense of why they may have
constructed the buddhist terrorists what
they did and b
um
you
have some context that's actually
temporarily appropriate to where you
find the box and it doesn't necessarily
throw things out of whack
again this is something to validate with
more with uh more field work i think
yes
please
please do
appreciate it
thank you for that fascinating question
and thank you andrew for such a
wonderful engaging talk in the q a um
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
stop the recording now and then leave
the chat leave the session open for
another 15 minutes or so for informal
chit chat you can imagine this everyone
is after the talk you can come up to the
podium and chat with the speaker so i
will stop the recording right now and
please stay if you feel like it